- Hi.
- This is a cute dress, too!
- Thank you, thank you.
I actually busted the belt,
so we just had to sew it in the car,
(Kelly laughs)
but we're here,
we're doing it, thank you.
- Meet Tinashe, meet Jeff.
- Hi, guys.
(audience applauding)
- So Jeff's family named him Chex Mix,
so how did you get the name Tinx?
- So when I was younger, I
actually wasn't that confident.
And so I watched this movie
and there was a character
in this movie called "All I
Wanna Do" called Tinka Parker,
and she was like the coolest girl.
And I told my friends, I was like,
"Guys, I have an alter ego now.
Her name is Tinka Parker."
And when I'm her, I'm confident,
and I'm cool and whatever.
And slowly, I just started
to become more confident,
and slowly, they just started
to call me Tinka Parker,
then Tinka, then Tinx.
So I've been called Tinx
for like 20 years now.
- That's cute.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience claps)
It's like my Sasha Fierce moment.
We all need a nickname, an alter ego.
- It is funny,
I don't know if y'all feel
this when you're on stage,
but I do feel different,
and I do feel more bold and confident.
Do you feel like that
when you're on stage?
- Absolutely.
There's this part of me, I call her Nashe,
I just drop the first syllable of my name.
(audience cheers)
She is this super confident,
it's weird 'cause it lives
inside of you already,
but it gives the opportunity
to feel like you can kind of-
- Absolutely.
- Step into that.
- Do you feel like that
on stage, more confident?
- I just, yeah, I just feel
like I'm talking to my friends,
so I look forward to it.
- Oh, I think that's why
people love you though, too,
'cause you're so relatable in that sense.
It's conversational.
- Yeah.
Everybody loves everybody here.
So wait, so you've got millions
of followers on social.
So how did this all start for you?
- So it started in quarantine.
I downloaded TikTok to try to stay sane,
and I just, I kind of
was like at rock bottom,
as we all were, going out of our minds.
And I was like "You know what?
I don't care anymore.
I'm just gonna to try this.
I'm just gonna make a video."
And as soon as I made my
first TikTok, I was like,
"This is what I'm supposed to
do with the rest of my life."
I wanna entertain people.
I wanna connect with people.
I wanna make videos,
and the rest is history.
- You're very funny.
And the one-
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
- One of the videos,
it's hilarious, 'cause you're like,
"So it was my daily cry during pandemic,"
'cause everybody did have
their daily moment of like-
- We have your daily cry.
You gotta put it in the
schedule right between-
- But it was so dry-
- Organizing sweatpants-
- Your wit.
- And eating rotisserie chicken,
standing up in your kitchen.
It was a busy time for everybody.
- You don't have time to sit down.
You've all the time to
sit down, but we're not.
So wait, so you're known as
the big sister of TikTok.
So when did people start
to come to you for advice?
'Cause I love that.
- It was honestly pretty
immediate, and it's great.
And I think that I love to ask for advice,
and I think it's two
sides of the same coin.
I love to ask it, I love to give it.
It's all about sharing information.
And if I can pass on a tip to another girl
and save her a little
bit of time or angst,
that's a win.
That's what life is about.
(audience claps)
- I'm not gonna lie.
I've definitely seen some of your TikToks
going through it in 2020,
and been like, that was some
real stuff that she said.
- I cried a lot on the internet
in the past year and a half.
- [Tinashe] Yeah, but it helped.
- Yeah, I had a really bad breakup.
And I made a video, and I
was like, I got cheated on,
and I made a video saying
I'm not embarrassed
that I fell in love and trusted someone.
And I put it out there.
I was like, why not?
And I got so many
messages of girls saying,
"This helped me," "We've all been there."
- We've all been there.
- "It's a bad time,
but we've all been there."
- And it's so true.
For some reason, women or men,
I know guys have been cheated on too,
everybody goes to like,
"What did I do wrong?"
or "Why would they do that?"
And it's like, "Wait, what?"
- Yeah, exactly.
It's not about you.
It's about the other person.
It's not embarrassing.
It's just, you got your heart stomped on.
- Yeah.
I like being open like that.
My mother is always shocked.
(audience laughing)
But whatever.
So wait, your new podcast
is called "It's Me, Tinx."
So do you give advice on the podcast too?
Is that how it came-
- I do.
I give advice on the podcast.
We talk about literally everything.
As you were saying, I love to be open.
And I also have a radio show
every Wednesday that's live call-in.
So people can call in and ask me-
- That's Sirius, right, on XM?
- On SiriusXM Stars, yeah, channel 109.
And it's just so fun.
I had my first one yesterday.
And to hear my followers' voices
and to just talk through
problems with them,
it was the best feeling in the world.
- Especially for someone,
I love conversation,
and I love learning and
progressing, so it's perfect.
What a great job-
- It's really fun.
- For somebody that loves that.
- Thank you, thank you.
- That's so cool.
Okay, it's time for another little break.
You can listen to Tinx's new
podcast, "It's Me, Tinx,"
wherever you get your podcast.